hey guys it's justine and i'm so excited
because today i'm actually at the
microsoft lounge and we have a bunch of
new microsoft goodies that we're gonna
check out today there's two that i'm
very very excited about number one is
the new surface duo two the first
version of this thing i was such a huge
fan of and the updates they've made in
this version too are so exciting there's
also something new in the lineup and
this is something that looks really
incredible i'm so excited to show it to
you guys it's the surface laptop studio
come on let's go check it out so here's
everything new that was announced this
is the surface laptop studio we've got
the surface duo 2. this is the new pro 8
this is the go 3 and the upgraded pro x
this is also something that's really
exciting this is their ocean plastic
mouse so this is using recycled plastic
from the ocean it hasn't actually been
unboxed yet so
maybe
i'm getting some nods that i can unbox
it this is something else that they
announced this is the microsoft surface
adaptive kit so this is allowing for all
of these devices and any other devices
that you might have at home to become
more accessible
[Music]
to these surface duos i'm so excited
about this i feel like all of the things
that we felt were not quite there in the
first version they addressed all of that
including the cameras we've got the wide
ultra wide and telephoto and there's
even one on the inside if you guys
remember you had to do kind of like this
little weird kind of maneuver to like
flip this over to try to get a shot but
now they've got cameras not only on the
back but one on the front as well one of
the things that i really like is oh my
goodness it's happening this is a new
notification spine so one of the things
that was difficult before is you didn't
know what was actually happening inside
but now
i can tell i'm getting a phone call
[Music]
hello
extended warranty like if i want an
extended warranty like i'm gonna go to
the dealership and i'm gonna get it
myself
anyway the notifications are so cool so
if i click this i can actually see the
time and i can see the little phone call
notification right there i also feel
like it's so subtle that no one's
actually gonna know that i'm looking at
my phone and checking the time
can you tell
i can tell you can tell yeah you're
looking at your phone okay shoot
but they don't know what i'm looking at
they've also made these screens a little
bit closer so it does feel like it's
more of a seamless experience
when you're switching from side to side
i like the new camera as well so we have
the ultra wide
the one x
the 2x and it's cool because this all
shows up here on the left side so i'm
able to go in and edit
they have an all new editing feature
here aspect ratio different adjustments
like exposure
brightness
we can pop a filter on there look at
that that's art
i'm selling that as an nft
[Music]
check this out this turns into like a
little controller
i love minecraft dungeons so much this
game is so fun
[Music]
so this is the surface laptop studio and
this is something that i'm really
excited about because this really is
kind of like an all new way of not only
consuming content but creating content
and working so this goes into three
different modes we've got our laptop
we've got our stage and then we have our
studio this is also running windows 11
so you'll notice that the user interface
is now centered and there's now even the
new slim pen with haptic feedback and
the first time that i tried this it was
wild i was drawing but it was actually
like i was drawing on some sort of paper
so like the pen it's it's crazy it's
hard to explain it's like giving a
little vibration so you can tell that
you're drawing are you saying it feels
like a friction yeah it feels like i'm
drawing on paper you can also use the
new pen on the surface 202 which is
exciting
[Music]
so this is the new pro 8 and they've got
a nice little secret spot here for the
new slim pen this also has faster
connections with thunderbolt 4 ports
this actually has up to 27 faster cpu so
this is one of their most powerful pros
ever
so there's only one and jen and i are
both making a video so we decided to
unbox the ocean plastic mouse together
okay jen pull the tab nice
whoa
it's so neat this is really cool that's
one of my favorite colors yeah whoa wow
what's really cool is that all these
will have a unique design since they are
made from recycled plastic this is
awesome i really like it i like the size
too i feel like this is a good travel
mouse as well well this was just a quick
first look at some of the things that
microsoft announced i'm so excited i'm
such a huge fan of all of the surface
products and man of my hype about this
surface 202. i can't wait to actually
get my hands on one of these and really
get a chance to test it out if you guys
haven't already be sure to subscribe hit
the bell to be notified when i post new
videos and leave me some comments below
and let me know what was the coolest
thing that you saw today bye
[Music]